I like driving I like driving my car I
love driving cross-country on road trips
but only like cars or racing Gran
Turismo and Forza don't really excite me
but I did like the crew I like to cross
country driving the crew but you know
that game had its own problems Sony pit
speed and car culture thing didn't
really having to excite play it but I
enjoyed rivals so you know I thought
give it a shot but not being into that
whole street racing at night card holder
thing I wasn't really expecting much out
of it so the first thing I did when I
got into the game was by the lamest God
possible to write it on your car friend
that happened to be the boxee vulvar 242
which is pretty funny to me because
that's the kind of cars parents drove
around here in the 80s get ready my man
here goes nothing
I later found out that this Volvo is
actually really popular with car
enthusiasts and Sweden that are still
amusing to me even after like five hours
or so
so it turns out this call can actually
hold its own and soon I was learning how
to drift properly and take particular
turns and I think mainly this was
because i was taking missions from
certain characters you know the ones i
found less annoying than the others the
ones i actually wanted to kind of hang
out with huh what does that mean is that
good i see how it is dog you should come
from money we raise the stakes a little
huh yeah four dollars eventually I had a
crap load of cash and I'd already
unlocked all the upgrades my Volvo so i
bought the only other car i knew of
actually you know light which was the
ford mustang boss Kaline we're just
about ready to kick things off
so after I bought the Mustang I started
taking the challenges from the rest of
the crew even the ones I thought were
really annoying because you know as
silly as this all sounds like the fake
group of friends was actually growing on
me you know even that little you know
group plot dramas and stuff and they'll
teaching me how to be a better race at
the same time so I figured why not even
though I didn't like the challenges
themselves you know I would learn how to
do new things and each of them just
getting started baby but then one of
them still a Porsche from another racer
and I'm still not sure I'm cool with
that but then they let me drive it so
that was pretty cool
gamespot producer Andy Baumann tells me
EA has sort of a soft exclusive thing
with poor so he was excited that there
was a bunch of Porsche cars in the game
which made me excited about it you know
even though I don't really give a [ __ ]
about porsche having that car enthusiasm
rub off on me who's definitely enhancing
my experience and that's kind of the
same thing with Nick feet you know you
hang out with these people they might
seem like a bunch of losers at first but
they grow on you and you just want to
help them basically enable their
enthusiasm to this hobby and it gives
you a good feeling couponing you back
man oh I kind of love it and hate it you
know they don't judge me for driving my
stock baby blue Volvo and using it to
drift next to them or anything so I
guess they must be pretty cool with it
too which means they're really nice
people deep down hey you have to let me
post these bill pics man they do talk on
the phone a lot while we're driving
though and that's something you
definitely shouldn't be doing not a
drive deep in a mano hey what's this I
hear about my boy swag is weighing your
crew wow so I guess that means like like
racing games now well thanks to this
ragtag group of fake cough people
laughing diner
last ones in the diner picks up
everybody's tab what
you